al inicio de la guerra junto a sus dos
hijos tatiana a fans lleva tuvo que
dejar atrás a su marido llamado al
combate y huir a polonia instalados en
un apartamento de poznán seis meses
después tatiana no deja de soñar con
regresar pero aunque su ciudad natal
crivelli ha vuelto a una relativa calma
el miedo aún la paraliza
serie y la gente se ha acostumbrado en
la guerra cuando escuchan sirenas
antiaéreas simplemente se dan la vuelta
y siguen durmiendo en uno podría decir
acepto esto pero no creo que pueda
manejarlo ella es una de los más de diez
millones y medio de ucranianos
principalmente mujeres y niños que según
la agencia de la onu para los refugiados
han cruzado las fronteras de su país
desde que inició la invasión rusa el 24
de febrero la mayoría se ha quedado en
países vecinos como polonia que ha
recibido a más de 12 millones de
refugiados alemania ha guardado a casi
un millón y otras naciones como
república checa o italia a 400.000 o
150.000 respectivamente entre tanto a
rusia acnur calcula que han llegado más
de 2,1 millones de ucranianos
como muchos otros refugiados ha recibido
ayuda de gobiernos vecinos y de sus
ciudadanos pero tras una avalancha
inicial de apoyo público la
desaceleración económica que se extiende
por europa podría menguar el apoyo y
dificultar aún más la situación de los
refugiados entre tanto al interior de
ucrania en regiones como donets muchos
civiles continúan huyendo de los ataques
por lo que la crisis de refugiados está
al igual que la guerra lejos de acabar
hay pocas complicaciones al partir ahora
aún así sientes mucha presión al dejar
tu ciudad natal tu querido el lugar
donde naciste y creciste todo lo que
tienes se quede allí la mayoría de ellos
como tatiana y sus hijos no saben cuando
sus hogares volverán a ser un lugar
seguro